hello everyone on behalf of Agri links
speed the future and the USAID Bureau
for food security I would like to
welcome you to our webinar today on
measuring performance and Agricultural
Extension a common metrics framework my
name is Julie McCarty and I'm with the
USA Bureau for food security and I'll be
your webinar facilitator today so you'll
hear my voice periodically especially
during our question-and-answer session
before we dive into the content I'd like
to go over a few housekeeping items to
orient you to the webinar first and many
of you have done this already please do
use the chat box to introduce yourselves
and let us know where you're coming from
the chat box is your main way to
communicate today and we encourage you
to use it to post your questions at any
point to share resources and to discuss
this topic with your colleagues we'll be
collecting your questions throughout the
webinar and we'll try to answer some of
them along the way in the chat box and
we'll hold the rest until after the
presentation you'll see that the slides
are currently available for download and
the little box in the bottom left of
your screen and they're also some
recommended links so we encourage you to
explore those throughout the webinar and
lastly we are recording this webinar and
we'll e-mail you the recording the
transcript and some additional resources
once they are ready and they'll also be
posted on the iGrow links website so
you'll be able to forward this on to
your colleagues as desired all right
let's talk about extensions as many of
you know Agricultural Extension and
advisory services provide essential
support to small holder farmers by
providing them with the knowledge and
tools about modern practices and
technologies by facilitating co-learning
within communities and by increasing
access to finance and market solutions
among other roles and as such AG
extension is very fundamental to see the
futures work with small holder farming
communities I expect that many of you
have joined today because you see value
in having an established set of metrics
to compare and contrast the performance
of extension systems across different
countries and contexts and feed the
future of developing local extension
capacity or elect projects as leading an
initiative to develop a common
work for extension metrics and we're
excited to have three speakers on hand
today to discuss this so I'll go ahead
and introduce our speakers and then I
will hand it over to them all right so
first up will be Kristin Davis who is a
senior research fellow with the
International Food Policy Research
Institute and has been there since 2004
her research involves research and
capacity strengthening on Agricultural
Extension education and agricultural
innovation systems and she is currently
the project director for the USA funded
project developing local extension
capacity or a d-league
next up will be David Spielman who is a
senior research fellow also at spring
and has also been there since 2004 and
he leaves the Institute's program on
science technology and innovation policy
and then we will also have Judy Paine
who was USAID's digital solutions
advisor for agriculture until just
recently in 2017 and is now an
independent consultant with the same
focus and she's currently helping us aid
missions and their projects use digital
tools to increase thank you very much
Julie and good day to all of you thank
you so much for joining this webinar and
I hope we'll have plenty of time for
discussion so I'm going to try to
advance the slides here and start with
an introduction to the topic and I'd
like to give you some background on the
initiative that Julie mentioned to
develop a common framework for extension
metrics to date no common framework
exists but we do see value in having a
common set of metrics to consistently
assess extension performance across
countries and also across contexts
I think a set of common metrics would
help us to share and adapt learning to
guide policymakers and funders
and implementers as well with regard to
how to invest in extension also just to
innovate and to maximize impact as I
said there is no common framework but
where the initiative started then was
with the best fit framework which is a
conceptual framework developed by the
International Food Policy Research
Institute the best fit framework
suggests an impact chain approach but
first let me explain a little bit more
what this framework is all about the
premise of the best fit framework is
there is no one-size-fits-all solution
to extension and advisory services and
we need local context specific and
customized or best fit solutions to
designing impactful extension how does
this work we start with the extension
system characteristics and these have to
be adopted or fit to the frame
conditions and you can see the frame
conditions here surrounding the box in
green it's the political system whether
it's centralized or decentralized it's
the farming systems and production input
and output markets it's the business
environment and civil society etc just a
little pause here Julie to make sure
everything's working fine no problems
good gonna continue great so let's dig a
little deeper here into the
characteristics of the extension system
and how they lead to performance in the
previous slide here I showed you how the
characteristics lead to performance
which lead to outcomes or changes in
behavior and then ultimate impacts
digging a little deeper into the
extension system characteristics and how
they affect the performance we first of
all have governance and management
structures things like human resource
management
and the incentives and career paths if
any monitoring and evaluation we then
have both organizational and individual
capacities of the extension services and
for individual agents this includes
technical skills but also your
functional or soft skills as well which
they need for their job and then we also
have the methods which characterize
extension services the ways in which
extension interacts with farmers
depending on their audience whether
they're trying to reach women or youth
teach something complicated where you
might use farmer field schools or
something where you use radio or
demonstrations all of these
characteristics which as I said are fit
to the frame conditions then affect the
performance of the systems and by
performance we're talking about things
like quality relevance timeliness demand
Drive effectiveness and efficiency but
where the best fit framework falls short
is in establishing a common set of
indicators against which to measure
performance so that's what we want to
talk about today and that brings us to
the initiative for a common framework
for metrics the initiative as Julie
mentioned is led by the Feed the Future
developing local extension capacity
together with Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation the World Bank and of course
USAID and this initiative came out of
some joint discussions on how to
transform extension globally including
things like pluralism and the use of
information and communication
technologies or ICT there is a task
force within the initiative that is
working on this framework for common
metrics which will be discussed actually
in a face-to-face meeting in Uganda in
February 2019 and we're hoping to bring
together some potential adopters of the
framework especially government's to see
how they're going to use the framework
and what we can do with it the task
force up front decided that the metrics
we're going to look at are going to be
aspirational which means data that we
want to
not necessarily that we know we can get
but also we'll focus on the public
sector but within a pluralistic context
and perhaps with modules for further
users like the private sector and civil
society what have we done to date as the
extension metrics taskforce we've come
up with a set of definitions of terms
we've come up with a framework for the
common metrics that includes outcome
pillars or goals of extension the target
audience and the domains across which we
would like to measure extension and then
we've taken and mapped potential metrics
or data or indicators across the
framework across the pillars the target
audience and the domains to identify
gaps and overlaps and I'm going to cover
each of one of these one by one
very quickly we have to find extension
and advisory services broadly and in a
pluralistic sense to be all of the
services and information needed and
demanded by producers that is aimed at
developing their technical
organizational and management capacity
and empowering them to make better
decisions with regard to their
agricultural enterprise we then looked
at the ultimate goals or the outcome
pillars that most extension services
have they have one or more of these
goals one of these is with regard to
productivity and income
this means that producers are reaching
their max maximum productivity and
income potential from the agricultural
activities a second goal many extension
programs have is sustainable resilience
where producers mitigate adapt to and
recover from shocks and stresses in a
way that reduces chronic vulnerability
while at the same time ensuring
environmental sustainability and then a
third pillar is surrounding empowerment
and equity and here we're saying that
all producers including those that are
marginalized or vulnerable the poor
sometimes women youth pastor
lists all of these people have access to
fair agricultural opportunities to
agency and to human capital in order to
make better farming decisions so those
are our pillars looking at the target
audience I said we're going to focus on
the public sector this is your
government's your public research
organisations your policymakers but we
also think this framework might be
applicable to the private sector
agribusinesses private service providers
and then broadly defined to civil
society as well these include your
donors nonprofits and NGOs cooperatives
and farming farmer organizations and
then the last area we looking at is the
domains within the extension system we
start with the systems which are your
overall extension structures the
institutions networks and incentive
things like linkages between
organizations or policies that guide
extension or even your share of the
public budget the second area is that of
inputs these are the resources that are
used to implement extension activities
like your extension agent workforce the
government budget per household and
things like that the third domain is
that of delivery the processes and
actions taken to achieve outputs and
deliver or achieve outcomes and this is
your organization and management Quality
Assurance training or even use of ICT
information and communication
technologies we then have your outputs
which are the most immediate set of
accomplishments necessary but not
sufficient to produce the outcomes which
are your changes in behavior things like
the households reached are included
within the outputs and then lastly we
have outcomes these are as I said your
changes in behavior these are immediate
intermediate observable and measurable
changes that can be attributed to
extension and can result in ultimate
impacts things like adoption change in
behavior change in attitude
knowledge there's one area we did not
include and it would be interesting to
discuss and that is the ultimate impacts
that's mentioned here these are very
difficult to measure and also difficult
to attribute to extension programs and
Judy and David might discuss that
further we'll see but any arm have done
here is to give you some background on
the extension metrics initiative and a
quick overview of what we've done in
terms of definitions and the start of
the common framework the outcome pillars
the target audience and the domains and
with that I'd like to turn it over to my
colleague dr. David Spellman to start to
talk about the challenges of extension
metrics Thanks all right thanks Kristin
I hope everybody can still hear me it's
great to have such a large audience on
Agri links with an interesting extension
metrics and it's very consistent as this
large audience with the evolution of
thinking in many quarters on extension
you know in which we're moving from
what's historically been a very strong
focus on research metrics that is the
upstream source of Science and
Technology for agricultural growth and
transformation to a new and very much
complementary focus on the last mile and
the downstream solutions for getting
products and services to people which
includes information and extension
recommendations so you know quite
naturally we want to have indicators
benchmarks and baselines to gauge
progress on this front on our sort of
investments or our programs or our
projects in extension but let me offer a
quick sort of reality check there are
some fundamental challenges in measuring
extension so let's start with you know
what you might call sort of a an
epistemological debate at a very basic
level it can be argued that extension
cannot be isolated or identified at
least not in the way we define extension
in our theory of change that Kristin
presented in the earlier slides Emily
let's face it do we really know what
individuals employed by the Agricole
chiral service organization are doing
are they providing farmers with advice
or are they doing other things
monitoring crop production distributing
fertilizer and other inputs collecting
on overdue loans and so on an even
extension can be isolated or identified
can it be quantified can quantitative
measures adequately explain a complex
system that is specific to farming
systems or Agri ecology society culture
economy and so on and even if it can be
quantified are we sure we have a
complete understanding of how extension
works are we sure that extension leads
to better farmers or do better farmers
simply seek out extension services all
right let me make sure that everybody
can still hear me yeah I think I'm good
and then continuing this sort of leads
us to the broader debate of wear
indicators matter in our identified
theory of change along with the impact
pathway we have to think carefully about
what we're trying to measure are they
proximate input indicators on sort of
the level and reach of extension or are
they more sort of you know distant
outcome indicators such as the causal
relationship between extension and these
productivity income or sustainability
outcomes of the care about we have to
think carefully about the importance of
attributing causality which Kristin
referred to earlier or really
understanding that relationship between
extension on the one hand and those
outcomes of interest that we care about
and trying to demonstrate that they're
more than simple correlations and that
we're accounting for confounding factors
in other words is there really a link
between receiving extension services and
you know improving your crop yields or
you know improving the sustainability of
farming or improving the welfare or
income of a household or members of that
household it's a tough question
all right but let's put those things
aside for a moment and assume that we're
comfortable with the idea the very idea
of measuring extension so now we have to
select construct and interpret some set
of indicators but there's no an
internationally accepted standard of
what can be classified as say public
spending on extension or who's
considered an extension astoria Nagant
or how to classify how to classify
capital equipment used in extension
service provision so thankfully we have
some precedent to build on here an
analogous set of questions and an
analogous exercise began in the late
nineteen eighty in the measurement of
agricultural research it frees
agricultural Science and Technology
indicators for instance collects
compiled and disseminates
internationally comparable data and
information on investment in
agricultural research its advantage and
what makes it distinct from the exercise
we're talking about today on extension
is that the a few metrics draw on
comprehensive definitions of what
constitutes research that were developed
by the OECD and laid out in their
Frascati manual so maybe in the
measurement of extension we need to
develop something similar maybe it's up
to us to develop that manual or that
guidance on how to measure extension and
what constitutes extension so a key
principle of the of the ASCII approach
or any approach really is that we need
to measure extension or whatever it is
we're measuring at the point where the
actual action takes place it's the
principle of subsidiarity in asti they
look at the Agricultural Research Center
or Institute or at the university
research program or lab that same
principle applied to extension though is
a bit trickier and what scale -
extension metrics make analytical sense
for data collection or for other
purposes do we measure extension at sort
of the central or federal level or do we
go hunting for data on extension at the
state or provincial level or at the
county and district level or even
further down at a very local sort of
village or community level do we measure
by geography agro ecology farming system
commodity or value chain those are very
different units of an
and do we focus on measuring public
extension only or do we try to get
proprietary information from private
firms on their customer support and
advisory services so all of this
suggests the need for data collection
and I would argue that if we want to
track extension metrics over time and
space which is certainly the the goal of
this conversation we need to collect new
data and definitely not repackage
existing data but collecting new data
costs a lot of money thankfully several
new initiatives out there can help us
either by bringing useful data into our
reach or by providing us with new data
collection methods for example consider
the World Bank living standards
measurement survey and it's integrated
surveys on agriculture which provides
cross country comparability on questions
such as whether a respondent has met
with an extension officer in the last
year or so or consider the women's
empowerment indicators under the women's
empowerment in agriculture index has
been developed by my colleagues of mine
here in history and elsewhere way the
way assembles novel data and analytics
on how men and women live work and
interact in the context of developing
country agriculture and a lot of these
data points could be used to obtain a
very valuable gendered perspective on
extension provision and performance so
that leads us to what I think is really
the essential question or the biggest
challenge can extension metrics actually
influence policy change for example by
encouraging governments to invest more
in extension or to undertake meaningful
structural reforms in extension I think
that the world has made tremendous
progress in using evidence data evidence
like we're talking about here to advance
policy change but we all know that there
are other factors like political
imperatives that affect policy change
much more than simply a set of good
metrics more importantly even if we
assume that our metrics have merit we
still need to ask if metrics are the
right
to either a lot of very powerful people
talk about using metrics to name and
shame or rank and spank countries who
don't invest enough in development
priorities but does that get us to the
outcomes we really want you know
extension systems are not a competitive
sports league like say the English
Premier League and the standings are
there on the screen in front of you or
the National Football League here in the
United States where team rankings points
and other statistics are the very
essence of the game a metric has to be
actionable to be policy relevant
otherwise how does a policymaker do
anything about a low score or a low rank
and a metric also has to be substantive
so that policymakers cannot simply game
the system by investing in one topic or
solving one particular problem to
somehow move themselves up the ranks
there's been a lot of critique of the
World Bank's Ease of Doing Business
Index or data collection and analysis
project along these lines and it's
something to think about very carefully
so having said all that I think an
attempt to measure extension is is a
tremendously good idea and we're
fortunate that the Gates Foundation the
Bullet Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
along with several other key
organizations have taken a stab at this
challenge to guide their own investments
and their own grant making so what you
have in front of you is a list of key
indicators that the foundation is
considering for their extension
dashboard they form what I would argue
is a good starting point for any country
or program considering an investment in
developing local extension capacity I'll
walk through them very quickly for you
and we can talk more about them later if
you like
they are for instance the share of
public budget spent on extension and we
would normalize that by dividing it by
the total agricultural budget so sort of
a percentage-wise intensity measure we
could also normalize that on a per
household basis an interesting metric
that they're proposing is financial
incentives for extension agents such as
the ratio of an extension agent daily
wage to let's say a royalty
daily wage continuous improvement
processes so the proportion of extension
personnel annually trained in
specialized courses households directly
reached by public extension again that's
a fairly standard measure but an
important one
households reached by all extension
whether it's from the public sector or
from the private sector or from civil
society organizations the quality of
public extension the share of households
for instance reporting the public
extension services were at least
somewhat useful on a Likert scale kind
of measure or service to female farmers
the share of females in small holder
households reporting that they received
extension services or inclusivity that
is something like maybe an index of
inclusivity of extension services
relative to some defined disenfranchised
or underserved population so these are
probably some of the metrics that we
should be considering and I and I would
argue they're a great starting point for
this kind of initiative and on that note
let me just wind up my remarks simply by
encouraging everyone to think about the
feasibility relevance and influence of
these kind of metrics in their own
context be it their own country context
the agroecology that are concerned about
the farming systems that they that they
observe the provinces or states they
work in or the value chains and
commodities that they focus on and with
that let me hand it off to Judy Dane
thank you very much thank you Davis um I
assumed the handlers of Agri links will
let me know if I'm not being heard well
unlike Kristin and David I do not have a
research background and the academic
discipline and clear experience that
they have pardon
I come from I came from the US private
sector and then spent about a decade at
US aid and have at least as strong as
interest as as Kristen and David and the
others on the small task force we put
together on figuring out better metrics
for extension I'm especially interested
in cost-effectiveness of extension
I've given I've worked for government
and of course are insured by government
and also the impact of extension on the
poor especially I focus on digitally
enabled extension and visually enabled
extension providers and users often
assume impact and cost effectiveness
when that's not the case or it certainly
shouldn't be assumed it may be other
proven techniques are better so I think
these metrics will help us get at that
I'm just going to pose a few questions
and hope that they'll provoke thoughts
from the audience and participation and
additional questions from you
I wanted to point out that this is we're
presenting this as a point in time it's
definitely a work in progress the
informal task force of a handful of
people is working towards the convening
that Kristen mentioned that we hope to
have in early 2019 but we wanted to open
up the discussion to more people to get
feedback we know the metrics we have and
the work that we're doing is not is not
as good as it can get and we hope to get
it much better before 2019 so please
study these slides and give us feedback
during the discussion but also
afterwards you can contact any of us and
also our colleagues at the Gates
Foundation and the World Bank as well so
I'll pose a couple of questions just to
get the thinking going a thing that
asked about whether this would influence
decision-making and there is a concern
that we
try to set this up in some way for
governments to compete but I desert that
if we can find some agreed-upon metrics
and even one country or two can stand up
and say I'm willing to be measured
against that and show that they've made
progress I think that alone would be a
great success and then other countries
might follow again it's not like they're
doing business indicators but it still
would be I think a point of pride for
governments that are really struggling
and working on improving their extension
services so I think for decisions
policymaking it could have an effect
that we do know and we want governments
that are working on extension to
participate in this convening to see
whether they find these measures useful
Kristen also pointed out that we're
looking at fresh aspirational measures
right now hold on just a minute I want
to just to make sure everything's going
okay I will get out of full screen just
to make sure okay I think we're just
fine so
the rational versus actually indicators
that we can use now David actually
pointed out the many challenges to have
metrics that we can collect for overtime
all those things are are certainly true
I'd say we still need to define things
as aspirational and then see how close
we can get with at least a few measures
to start out I'd be interested if you
think that we have forgotten any
critical measures here I'll go on to my
next slide we're have additional
questions or we are have we gotten
carried away I think one danger is that
we'll forget that most public extension
services are directed to help farmers
but especially poor farmers and do we
have enough indicators to balance that
interest or will we be applauding
extension services that go after the
most able farmers and are not rewarded
for doing the harder work sometimes of
making sure the more remote farmers the
remote households can benefit from
extension services before our convening
we want to make sure we've done homework
by talking with others in a broader
context and maybe you have ideas of
organizations you want to make sure we
talk with and it may be your
organization and how well will this be
accepted or we be useful by
agribusinesses say or or public or
private extension service providers are
these measures irrelevant can additional
ones be added is there metric some how
to tackle how well the public extend
service is leveraging private service
providers that's another really tough
one so there's there's lots of questions
again this is a starting point so we
look forward to a rich discussion I'm
honored that I get to be the sort of
provocateur on this and I'm very pleased
that we have people like Kristin and
David with such experience to keep us
self keep as disciplined as we go
through this effort so I think I'll turn
this over to Jimmy now who can figure
out what questions you all have great
thank you so much Judy and thanks also
to your dogs Waldo for his patience and
waiting for you to present if we've had
some fun side discussion about hearing
him a little bit but so there are a lot
of questions and comments coming in the
chat box which is wonderful so we'll go
back and start with some of the
questions that came in a bit earlier I
also wanted to reassure everyone that we
will be sharing the chatbox content with
the presenters so any comments you type
in that are answering some of the
provocative questions that judy has
asked your answers to those and your
commentary will go to the presenters and
the Judy mentioned there's also
opportunity to think about these and
provide commentary after this webinar
all right so looking back to some of the
earlier questions that came in let's see
all right Kristin or David perhaps I can
toss this one to Kristin to start
Viviani or Viviana Palmieri
asked is there any reason why the system
is limited to extension instead of
considering the broader innovation
systems or what other related systems
oh thanks okay go for it David I can I
can take that one viviana thank you very
much for the question
certainly measuring attributes of the
wider innovation system which includes
research and education business and
enterprise and the general enabling
environment the role of cooperatives and
extension among many other things is
important extension is just one element
in a larger agricultural innovation
system and we acknowledge that I think
what we're trying to achieve here is
simply putting some very small
boundaries around what we can measure
and hoping that contributes to broader
measurement of the innovation system so
for instance in AG innovation systems we
do measure agricultural R&D through
initiatives like Asti we also look at
you know measurements around educational
achievement and and performance systems
and whatnot through forum and others and
so on and so forth the task of measuring
every little aspect of an innovation
system is very very broad and very very
challenging that's why in this
particular exercise we're trying to
parse it out to something that's
directly relevant to sort of the the
investments and the the choices and
decisions that governments and their
development partners make to help them
inform that process that decision-making
process
thank you Kristin there are two
questions that came in from Mahesh
shondor during your presentation and so
I thought I'd ask
them both to you since they're sort of
short questions one was can we use the
same metrics for different extension
service providers and the other was
asking about measuring productivity
profitability
yes thanks very much Mahesh for joining
us from India can the same metrics be
used for different service providers
that very much depends on
the goal or the outcome pillars that
we're looking for so some providers
might be looking more for public goods
outcomes like food security and and
increasing incomes and others you know
might be looking for different goals and
outcomes so it's going to really depend
on your your goal and your pillar but we
are trying to make a modular approach
where you can sort of pick and choose
what what outcomes or indicators are
going to work for you and it's I'm
getting into Steve Fran's ELLs question
a little bit but we'll address that
later with regard to looking at the
overall matrix that we've come up with
you also asked about productivity versus
profitability and we actually had that
debate within the taskforce we started
off with productivity and then we said
but that's not the ultimate goal the
ultimate goal is maybe to improve
livelihoods or increase incomes or
something like that and so we do have an
element of productivity we might expand
that and you know it's not just crop
productivity there can also be factor
productivity issues as well but we do
include the element of profitability
because that's a step beyond the
productivity
excellent thank you all right let's jump
up to well you mentioned that Stephen
had asked a question so perhaps Kristen
we can jump to his question and Steve
asked how are the ten listed metrics
linked to the overall objectives goals
or desired impacts of extension that
would help us see gaps and overlap yeah
thanks Steve and Judy and David feel
free to chime in after I've said my bit
we do have a rather complex looking
matrix that has your your domains down
the left side and then the audience
across the right the pillars across the
right and then we've put in those
initial on Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation indicators as well as some
others that we've been looking at in
exactly to do that to see where are the
gaps and what we have seen is that there
are a number of gaps in outcome pillars
like sustainability and equity so those
are things that we're working on it's it
was really I think too tough to show to
a webinar type of audience but hopefully
we're going to have something out of the
task force in the coming months that we
can share publicly and you can see more
clearly how it goes this is Judy
echo what Kristen said we we were
limited to what we could present but the
matrix that Kristen refers to is is very
useful for taking a look at what we're
missing and the question of equity is
one where were where we need to think
much further
I think once we work a little bit more
we'll get that matrix in some form may
be multiple matrixes out there for more
review great thank you both
David I'll ask a couple of questions
that came in during your presentation
first up from Reginald to sense based on
your experience what is the minimum
timeframe to measure the impact of an
extension system alright that's it
that's a tricky question obviously if
you're trying to measure let's say the
impact of a large extension system
reform process right changing salaries
and incentives you know providing more
different infrastructure creating you
know new administrative routines and
procedures new leadership things like
that you know the IMP the the the time
frame may be anywhere from what two two
to five years five to ten years it's
very hard to say depending on it depends
on what outcome indicators you care
about things like profitability
productivity incomes and welfare
obviously take take some time to
manifest but in other in other instances
for instance you can measure the impact
of a very simple extension intervention
in a single season so I'll give you two
examples that we've worked on under
under the development local extension
capacity project funded by see the
future in US aid in Ethiopia working
with digital green and the government of
Ethiopia we examine the impact of a
video video enabled extension approach
on on farmers adoption of new crop
management practices
for the main cereal crops and we found
that after one season simply engaging
farmers in sort of you know video
screenings on new technologies and
practices that we saw increases in
adoption levels by five to eight
percentage points which are translated
into a much larger adoption rate on the
order of you know fifteen to twenty
percent against the the consuming of the
the control or what people were
otherwise doing in other words we saw
significant increases in adoption of new
technologies after one season simply by
the video extension approach in Uganda
we saw much of the same thing and after
one season we were focusing on maize and
the use of video enabled a video based
extension approaches we actually saw
increases not only an adoption but also
in yield maize yields based on what
people learned in the videos of how best
management practices recommended
management practices so if it's a simple
like ICT based intervention you can you
can measure a lot of impacts in one
season if it's a structural reform
process well that's a lot longer
great David and allow me to throw one
more out to you you would discuss you
know the difficulty of measuring
ultimate impacts I think my house gender
added another kind of layer to that
difficulty which is that impact is an
outcome of multiple factors so how to
isolate the impact due to extension or
should we even try what do you think
about that well like in the examples I
just gave from Ethiopia and Uganda as
well as work that other colleagues of
mine have done in India Aroo and many
other countries I I think with a
well-designed evaluation strategy you
can definitely measure the impact of
very specific extension interventions to
give you the example of what one of my
colleagues didn't Peru he he looked at
what they looked at the the impact of
providing agronomic recommendations to
children in high schools and trying to
measure whether that affected what their
parents did back on the farm and in fact
they found significant effects of this
sort of intergenerational transfer of
information that's pretty exciting right
you know give extension messages in a
school and and lo and behold the parents
actually adopt you know new practices on
the farm so so you can certainly measure
some of these things the question is you
know how what are you trying to measure
how broad are you trying to measure with
good evaluation design you can measure a
lot of things but like I said earlier if
we're talking about systemic reforms you
probably need a lot more data to be able
to you know control for or account for
confounding influences like changes in
the in the political winds or changes in
you know the weather over time things
like that or changes in market forces
and prices as long as you can count for
those kind of factors there is
possibility to to
to suss out the impact of extension its
but it can be challenging both in terms
of data and and sort of quality of
inquiry so you know your evaluation
strategy really matters but we do it all
the time we love to do it and it's
something that we would love to explore
with many of our partners great thank
you David and thank you to all of our
participants who are putting some really
excellent questions and comments in the
chat box all right so there were a
couple of questions that came in about
private service providers and so I'll
ask them both and we can perhaps answer
them in combination
so Padma Singh asked about the
presenters thoughts on considering
service providers and angry
entrepreneurs as a target audience of
Agriculture X Agricultural Extension and
then the Catherine Killaloe wanted to
know about how does the private sector
compare in terms of cost effectiveness
of delivery and understanding those
business cases yes o process.i
conservative Judy first okay well I
think I would distinguish between
third-party service providers that are
providing digitally enabled extension
ones that would be providing it for
private agribusinesses as well as for
public extension service providers say
digital green does this so they would be
I would I would assume severally these
metrics would be relevant for them to be
able to prove that their services are
are worth paying for by the public
sector or an agribusiness so that would
be I think many of the made metrics
apply directly another category of
private sector folks in extension are
those that are say sectoral associate
Asians for coffee or cocoa these are
very large plantation operators for
pineapple or other large export crops a
very short list of metrics might be
relevant if they get public funds they
would care about the ones related to
equity but I'd love to hear candidates
who might be able to tell us whether
these are relevant or not you can just
actually let us know in the chat window
and we can later follow up so Kristin
and David probably have some comments as
well
all right if Kristin or David would like
to chime in on those so you feel free so
many good ones I'm I'm just doing my
best to sort through them all let's see
all right for Kristin
Marissa sternness asked are there
targets or guidelines for any of these
metrics once you get the data how would
you know if you're doing well for
example if they're I recommend oh thanks
or it's a very very good question and
that's an important one as well
it does depend on the indicator so the
fao for instance has some
recommendations of minimum budgets that
should be spent on extension services or
minimum number of extension agent to
Farmer ratio things like that but in in
general I think a lot of the things
there is going to be no no
recommendation perhaps at national level
maybe the organization implementing it
might have their own targets and so
forth interestingly I was on a webinar
yesterday with the UNDP
Green commodities program and they are
trying to set up a comparable sort of
way to diagnose extension systems that
would start with a baseline and give
scores over the years so there are some
related initiatives going on but David
or Judy I'm not sure if you want to add
anything to that
I can I can say I guess one thing I
think you know you can use metrics in so
many ways cross country comparability
for instance gives you the you know a
chance to see what those countries that
you like to compare yourself to are
doing and think of that in an
aspirational sensing okay China does
this we want to be like that or Ethiopia
does this we want to be like that for
instance but I think more importantly
for any given country a program these
types of indicators are simply good
to benchmark oh you know changes over
time and look at you know what types of
investments what type of personnel what
type of resources are being channeled
into extension and you know over the
years and is it improving or is it not
improving I mean and whether you know
people perceive quality changes in
relevance and usefulness of extension so
you can use it in so many different ways
I guess I guess you know like I was
saying earlier in my presentation part
what you probably don't want to do is
though is get into this you know sort of
competitive you know race to the top
race to the bottom because sometimes you
know the context is so specific that
it's you know one country is trying to
get to where another country is but the
systems are really different or the
challenges are really different you know
does that serve anybody's purpose or
policymakers try to game the system by
throwing money at extension without
thinking about you know quality or
administration or or incentives and
things like that does that really help
things so there are you know using using
extension indicators in different ways
is good using them cautiously is even
better this is Judy I have one related
comment actually it sort of veers us off
set the topic of goals although I think
that's a great question and that will
certainly depend on the comments of
Kristin David made I was thinking I've
read quite a bit about one acre fund
lately and it provides extension
services it provides financing it
provides input it provides a package of
things it doesn't worry about
distinguishing what its extension type
services are doing versus its other
services it's focused primarily on
scaling and outcome so that it's sort of
a counterpoint to that the for middle
effort we're talking about here and in a
way it makes it easier for many
organizations that might somewhat like
that to look for results
so maybe the third-party service
providers could keep that in mind and
give us comments on whether any of this
is even relevant if you've got some
focused goals of your own questions that
are really related I think to what you
were all just discussing about adapting
the content of the framework near and
jakka Rama Stan javo asked do we want a
measurement that is comparable globally
or something that is specific to the
needs and context of each country and
Marisa our new staffs are really good
question saying that these indicators
are geared towards governments or
measuring at a higher administration
level can they be adapted to community
level interventions from NGOs and how
well good questions no simple answers
I'm sure Kristin and David could chime
in as well if we get good measures
defined they certainly can be used at a
sub-national level between communities
and with civil society organizations
they'll just have to pick and choose and
figure out practical ways that they can
use them you know clearly they won't be
able to do as a rigorous of data
collection as would be possible without
an international organization like if
pre coming from the private sector I
tend to have a more practical outlook on
it being some is better than nothing at
all and if we have metrics that we've
together defines then all the better
so try to get try to use define metrics
and then figure out how well though you
are they'll work for you for your
organization your community
Kristin David do you have more
thoughtful comments I guess I guess just
to say that you know international
comparability has its pros and cons and
it can be useful for for instance for
international development partners
multilateral and bilateral donor
agencies in making investment choices
and decisions that's why the Gates
Foundation developed their bash their
dashboard after all that's why I'm sure
Feed the Future USA and many others care
about these these sort of international
comparability --zz that we're talking
about but of course at a government or
country level and that a look at an
organizational level they're also
important some degree of standardization
is helpful because again you can use a
baseline and benchmark and compare
whether it's between organizations or
states or countries or or whatever you
choose I think that's the key to
indicators well you know commonly
accepted indicators make life I think a
lot more useful or a lot a lot easier
then everybody choosing your own
indicators from Thomas Caffrey Osvald
how can the impact of extension services
be effectively measured when one farmer
may be receiving overlapping extension
support for example from public
Extension Service as well as from
private sector when coupled with
investment in new technology or input
that's a great question again it goes
back to the response again to Mahesh
earlier you know it depends on your
evaluation design and what you're trying
to measure so you know those are simply
questions you can ask well we regularly
ask them in in household farm household
surveys where we ask people farmers
where you know where do they get
information from about you know crop
acts or technology why and and we allow
for multiple responses might come from
public extension or
private extension sources or might be
some combination of both now you know
I've been in the field where a public
extension agent is working with it was a
corporate sales agent at the same time
to promote a new a new cultivar a new
hybrid a new you know a new machine or
something like that so yeah people work
in tandem people working in
collaborative ways I think that's
perfectly fine and and you know as long
as you're able to account for that and
have that information then you know you
can you can parse out you can parse out
the effects I mean you know sometimes
there's an art to this sometimes there's
a science to it it really depends on
what the intention of your evaluation is
if you're trying to say okay you know my
NGO did this and the government didn't
then then you know that's a fairly I
think narrow assessment approach or
evaluation approach if you're trying to
say well you know information from you
know these types of sources led to the
outcomes we care about then that might
be I think a more realistic way of
approaching the problem or the question
it really ultimately depends on what
your learning objectives and what your
evaluation objectives are in this case
great thank you David
all right let's see curtain I will show
a question to you from Vicki Sigmund is
the expectation that public sector
Extension will support ie pay for data
collection or otherwise what role will
they play if the public sector is to
support this then are there clear
indications or if I guess if the public
so there are there clear indication
thanks hi Vicki thanks for your
excellent question there is some
expectation that there will be interest
on the side of governments and actually
this is part of the role of the task
force now and the next few months is to
go and to start to talk to potential
governments that we think would be
interested and to see are they
interested in collecting extension
metrics and then invite them to the
convening in Uganda in February and sit
down and hash through it a little bit
more so how it's gonna be done is is yet
to be seen it might be different in
every country but there is the
expectation but there's going to be
funding whether it's coming from a sort
of an outside donor or governments in
terms of using these data to inform and
advocate for their policies for
extension that's that remains to be seen
Thank You Kristen and we still have some
good time for questions but I just
wanted to flag a few upcoming events and
activities on a burling's
first to feed the future learning agenda
the draft agenda for phase 2 FC the
future is currently open for public
comment and you can see the dress
learning agenda and a survey link for
commenting there next to number one
number two if you are a student or you
know one who is working in the food
security and agriculture space Agri
links is currently having a young
scholars blog contest but which students
can submit their blog post about their
work or their insights on global food
security and we're going to pick with a
panel of US aid and Agri links
individuals we're going to pick the top
blog post to published and feature on
Agri links so do encourage your student
students in your life to apply and
lastly we wanted to announce the October
theme month for every links right now
we're in extension month clearly but
next month is going to be value-added
food month which I'm really excited to
to talk about we'll probably be having a
webinar on orange flash super to potato
and been talking about all of the
entrepreneurial ways that farmers
processors other actors can add value to
food for better incomes and better
nutrition so keep all of those in mind
oh and I also wanted to point out in the
links box to your left you'll see a link
for the del X community of practice we
definitely encourage everyone on this
webinar to join that community of
practice the there will be a lot of
additional ways to discuss these topics
through that website and through some
webinar and other discussion
opportunities that Dee lek presents so
don't hesitate to join that COP alright
so back to oh we've got a bit of an a
large none of that links box we'll go
ahead and bring the head back dad so
that was just really telling you all to
click on those links excellent okay so
back
the questions that have come in okay I
will go to a question that came in from
Kathy Perry in the ten common metrics
the quality of public extension is a
metric but the same approach of
determining quality is not applied to
the private sector is it implicitly
implied that private sector extension
does not need to be assessed for quality
of extension and Judy was that one that
you could address sure I'll start how
many come from the private sector and
the private sector cares a lot about
success and it defines what did success
means if it's getting donor money of
course it cares a lot what donors care
about but say a private company that
owns pineapple plantation cares a lot
about productivity it cares a lot about
making sure its workers stick to them
and we hope are treated well but we
can't these metrics will be decided by
so they're not by the private sector but
maybe some of the others could chime in
but certainly any service provider cares
a lot about showing how effective their
services are so those metrics will be
truly relevant yeah I can quickly add to
that I'd say that we have some
experience on on the measurement of
agricultural research indicators to say
what's possible what's not possible
measuring both the levels and the the
type of private investment in
agricultural research for instance has
proven to be very difficult especially
for for initiatives like a steam which I
mentioned earlier
and that's largely because AG research
indicators that is you know investment
spending things like that
personnel and so on our proprietary
information they form for many companies
they form the basis of their competitive
advantage in the margin you know in very
competitive marketplaces so think along
the same lines our extension if you're a
an agro service provider of some sort
your private your profit-making you
don't necessarily you know want to give
out information on hey how many people
do we have on the ground providing after
sales support or providing you know
recommendations to farmers and advice on
an ad hoc basis or you know through our
call center or whatever it is that might
be proprietary information that you know
that that the company wants to protect
so that becomes very difficult to get so
you know but that doesn't imply that
it's not it's not the quality of private
extension is not an important measure as
Judy said you know people care about the
quality of their products in the private
sector as much if not more than they do
in the public sector so somebody's
measuring it it's a question of whether
it's going to be shared in the public
domain or not thank you
great thank you so much
I'd like to toss it back to you David
for a really interesting question that
came in from the Civic Amol Yan looking
at the gapes metrics what if we were to
reach 100 percent of households covered
by extension have a very generous public
budget service the females etc but no
essential increase in yield for hectare
no increase in production and trade are
those the most important and probably
the only metrics that matter
that's a great question doc I thought
earlier I had to laugh it's it's yes
it's precisely what one wants to be
asking the proof is in the pudding as
they say if you measure something but
you can't attribute that measurement to
some outcome of interest then then maybe
the problem the problem isn't your
measurement so much as it is your theory
of change so what you're basically
describing here is a situation in which
your theory of change doesn't stand up
to - you know empirical testing and that
extension has no effect on these
outcomes of interest in which case you
probably have to go back to the drawing
board and say well extension really has
nothing to do with you know productivity
profitability incomes welfare
environmental sustainability and so on
and so forth now of course whether you
know whether that's really the case is a
bigger question and and I think that's
again where we go back to a good
evaluation design and saying okay you
know we've got some measurements on
extension and now we want to go back and
make sure that that we're able to say
that you know these measurements are
somehow correlated and potentially infer
causality about their you know their
their influence on on outcomes so yeah
there's a lot of sort of you know
hypothesis testing and all of this not
just measurement and and that's
something we have to be very very I
think serious about in our work
thank you David and I would like to
throw out another question that came in
from Alma do if Sokka can we use the
same approach to measure quality
outcomes like for instance the
functionality of innovations platform
farmers capacity to mobilize funds from
institutions etc and that was for David
or Kristin you can fill in the gaps yeah
thanks for your question I mean I think
this is is an approach that can be
applied in other similar institutions I
mean extension is quite a complex
institution and then when you're getting
into innovation platforms and things
like that it includes even more
variables and actors and so forth but I
think the general setup of how we're
looking at this and applying things
based on those different domains as well
as the different outcome pillars I think
we could try to apply it to two similar
activities like innovation platforms and
so forth David
[Music]
so there's been some interesting work on
the measurement of the functionality of
innovation platforms for instance by it
by Pam book at Wageningen University in
the Netherlands and as well as
colleagues so so yeah and you can
certainly measure those types of outcome
you can measure things like farmer's
capacity to mobilize funds from
financial institutions and so on those
are all indicators that you can even
look at and whether they're linked to
extension you're thinking the theory
have changed and and how you measure it
one I would I would suggest that if
you're really interested in these topics
and and poking around in the data take a
look at those at the LSMs integrated
surveys on agriculture from the World
Bank that I mentioned earlier I mean
there's there's a incredible amount of
information there that people are really
digging through intensively to learn
more exactly the kind of questions
you're asking you know and and you know
I kind of sort of data analysis and
approaches are are key to answering but
they're but they're they're good ones
they're good ones to explore
Oh finally speaking alright okay
interesting comments came in from gear
Gary Alex that I thought that Kristin
could address so Gary said for an
understanding of extension systems it is
probably important to start from the
farmer level to understand the needs
objectives preferences and potential
actors too often we have gaps in the
understanding and perspective and treat
the farmer as a blank slate to be worked
on it is hard to think of how this might
be reflected in an indicator but it's
important yes hi Gary
my first comment is that we're going to
try to rope you into this task force I
don't know if John got in touch with you
yet but we'd love your inputs on it but
certainly for an extension program to be
to be relevant and as you say effective
and all of these things I mean it's got
to be relevant and useful to the
clientele and the extension services
need to have that client client oriented
approach
so we do need to have their opinions it
it would be interesting to look for some
indicators to reflect that and it's of
course again going to depend on our
ultimate program goals and program
objectives so if we're trying to empower
farmers and have a demand driven program
that's certainly one that we would want
to
oh great I think David you said you had
some additional comments
sure so so let me see if I can tackle
two comments one is related to what Gary
Alex said and another one from Andrea
borne on the importance of using data
collected from farmers to who to provide
feedback to farmers so so at these both
of these comments have a similar thread
or a similar vein which is that you know
you know often when we think about
metrics and indicators we're really
we're really top down and how we think
about things right we're thinking of
this big system level and we want to
measure things so we have international
comparability and we can you know steer
our investments in the right way well
that's all good and fine but if we don't
really understand sort of what's going
on at the grassroots level and if we're
not really using this type of
information to inform people at the
grassroots level then we're probably
falling short of our objectives and you
know I couldn't agree more I mean I
think that's exactly the way we should
be thinking about development processes
development processes economic and
social development do not occur on the
basis of what we think about in
Washington DC or Seattle or London or
Paris or wherever they happen at the
grassroots where people exist and the
more we think about farmers as a diverse
set of people that are more than just
farmers the better we are at
understanding how to tailor extension
services to fit their needs
one of the things we care about in
particular when we're looking at
indicators of you know how well is
extension achieving the outcomes that
were focused on is to think not at the
average effect size or the average the
magnitude of the average effects but
also to parse it out and think a little
bit about how certain subgroups are
affected so for instance thinking about
you know the work in Uganda Uganda has a
inordinately large number of women
headed households because of demographic
pressures pressures associated not just
with urbanization but also the hiv/aids
and
like that that the country has suffered
through for decades so focusing on that
particular sub population is really
important
women headed households are children and
youth headed household in Uganda are a
significant part of the population and
we don't think about much so focusing on
them getting you know getting a better
understanding what extension does and
doesn't do for them is a great way to to
address these these these issues so yes
I think starting from the bottom up and
worrying less about not worrying less
but but you know maintaining a balance
between what we think about the
grassroots and what we think of that
this this much higher systems levels is
necessary balance is everything thank
you great very interesting answers thank
you to both of you let's see we do have
about up to ten more minutes for
questions but in the meantime we wanted
to throw up a few poll questions for all
of you to help us better understand your
experience on the webinar so we'd love
to know how likely it is that you would
recommend this webinar to a friend or
colleague did anything surprise you from
the content of this webinar are you
walking with any new insights what was
not address that we could potentially
address in the future asking about if
you'd like to stay involved in the
common metrics initiative so that we can
continue to reach out to you and what
was most useful to your work so please
to let us know your answers to these
questions they'll help us better shape
future webinars and events all right
let's see we've got just a few more
questions that I think we can answer and
a question flash comment came in from
Suzanne Pullen's that I will toss out
Suzanne said farming is a business how
do business advisory services measure
impact what metrics do these business
advisory services use and could these be
relevant to farming businesses and other
agribusinesses and judy we thought
perhaps you could start on that question
actually I would ask Suzanne to bet
herself she's an expert on all of this
so and I learned a lot from her and I
hope to continue so I don't have any any
answer that
Suzanne probably wouldn't have herself
clearly farming is a business it's more
than a business it's a it's the
household livelihood
so measuring business services as part
of it as part of extension is a big
challenge
both Kristen and David are better
students of the definition of extension
and we're business advisory services fit
in so maybe they can comment on where
what metric would tackle that all right
and Judy let me toss another one out to
you from Padma Singh
how do we ensure that producers are
getting a fair share in benefit in
private sector extensions as the
governor or does the government have a
role here I say follow the money his
government has money in those service
services being provided or a donor does
then yes the government has a role in
measuring that and of course in some
countries there are rules about how
farmers or our service of those getting
services ash should be served or treated
clearly if a private company is
providing these services on its own for
its own gains and that of its owners
then the government has far less of a
role and given I came from the private
sector I
I certainly honor that private
businesses ever have
strong reasons to measure their own
success they surely have to protect
those that they serve through various
other laws but applying these metrics by
the government on totally private
service providers I don't think we'd
have to do that with great caution and
maybe do it voluntarily so that the
private services providers can have an
incentive to do it to show how well they
serve their audience to that question I
think there's a number of people on the
webinar Gary and Ontario
David and myself who have been trying to
measure extension and you know
struggling with with indicators and data
and so forth so it is a trade-off I mean
there's the data we ideally would like
to have and we're starting from there
and we're gonna try to get it and see
how it works
in the end its it might be necessary to
come down to you know what's gonna be
more feasible and more easy to collect
so we're gonna we're gonna see about
piloting this in one or more countries
and and take it from there and see what
works
[Music]
great Thank You Kristen
and David let me look way back to your
presentation for a question that came in
fairly early on from Hamid or Rahman who
said it is difficult to measure outcomes
in terms of monetary value is there any
good indicator available for the
researchers or just a little bit more
perspective on measuring monetary value
it depends on which outcomes you are
interested in monetary value can
certainly be measured to give you to
give you a sense we've been talking a
lot about profitability of farming or
farm activities so if we if we want to
put a monetary value on that you know we
look at we look at the costs and returns
to to cultivation of a particular crop
or commodity or the whole farms the
overall profitability you know when you
think about simply yield gains right you
can translate that into monetary value
by multiplying the quantity of
production increased multiplied by the
price of the crop that involved so that
gives it a monetary value income of
course is a monetary phenomenon welfare
can be measured in other ways apart from
income in both monetary and non-monetary
ways there are lots of different ways to
measure these things and they can you
know be boiled down to two monetary
measures or non-monetary as well what's
important I think is you know to get a
sense of sort of the you know the rate
of the differences in the rate of change
you know that are attributable to two
extension and those levels and trends
are what gives us a sense of performance
and impact thank you
thank you so much David all right so
we've had a lot of questions come in
some really great discussion we really
really appreciate all of you who have
joined us as attendees liberally sharing
your questions and comments they're very
helpful to the delecti who are helping
to create these metrics and of course
joining the DLX community of practice is
one of the best ways to continue to stay
informed on this topic in addition we'll
be sending out an email with the
recording of this webinar the
powerpoints a few additional resources
the chatbox transcript etc and in that
email we'll be sure to communicate any
essential follow-up actions from this
webinar so I'd like to go ahead and wrap
up the webinar and say a sincere thank
you to Judy David and Kristen for your
excellent presentations thank you to the
aggro links team who is always wonderful
and supporting and putting on these
webinars and most importantly thank you
to you the attendees for continuing to
come to a grilling Slover